-My first guest tonight
executive-produces and stars in
the new series
"The Flight Attendant,"
which premieres Thanksgiving Day
on HBO Max.
Here is Kaley Cuoco!
Oh, wow!
-Hey, guys.
-It's so good to see you.
-The fans go wild.
-I know. My gosh.
-It's so weird.
Hi, Jimmy!
-Thank you for
coming on the show.
I appreciate this.
And I'm psyched about
"The Flight Attendant."
-Thank you.
-Before the pandemic, though,
you were filming
"The Flight Attendant"
all over the world.
-Yes. Yes, it's quite an
international show.
We were in --
Before the pandemic, obviously,
we were in Thailand and then
we were in Rome for a while.
So right --
In January of last year.
-You were telling me that
in Italy, though,
you actually felt --
You felt like you were becoming
more like your character.
-I...
[ Laughs ]
-You have to tell the story,
'cause it's just, like --
It's awesome.
-So, my character, Cassie,
is kind of a hot mess --
a fun hot mess.
Loves to drink, loves to party.
So, one night in Rome, me and
the cast decided to go out
and be like, you know,
one of the locals.
So, we were with a couple guys
that lived in Rome
and knew the town.
So they brought us
to this amazing club.
Very small club.
Again, locals.
Like, no tourists.
The place was very small.
You're packed like sardines.
The music is, like,
loud, bumping.
I'm like -- I had never been to
anything like this before.
I walked in, and my first thing
that I clocked
in this very small club
were open candelabras.
So, like, imagine -- You know,
like "Beauty and the Beast."
Like, open flames.
-Right. Okay. Yeah. Sure.
-Right? So I'm like, "Wow,
that's --" And I clocked it.
I'm like, "That's got to be --
That's got to be
a little dangerous."
So we walk in, and, like,
"Eh, more shots, whatever."
-Yeah, it's like, "Yeah,
we're too concerned in America.
Come on. Let's be European.
This is cool."
-"Stop being so worried, Cuoco."
So, I'm sitting there.
I'm looking at my girlfriend.
I'm sitting at the bar and I'm
sitting at a tall chair.
And there's so many people.
And, all of a sudden,
my girlfriend --
I see her eyes go big,
and I smell smoke.
And I look around and I'm like,
"Do you smell that?"
And she goes -- And I see her,
like, motion that it's me.
Out of nowhere, this man comes
from behind me,
which I still don't know
that my hair
is the one that's on fire.
My hair has now caught on fire.
This man comes.
I think he's attacking me.
And I go, "Oh, my God!
This man..."
And I start hearing,
in the club, people chanting,
"Fuoco, fuoco, fuoco!"
And I'm like, "Oh, my God.
Not only is my hair on fire,
everyone in this club
is recognizing me."
They're, "Cuoco, Cuoco, Cuoco!"
-"Cuoco, Cuoco, Cuoco!"
Yeah, they're attacking you.
-They're attacking me.
And I'm like, "Oh, my God.
Like, I'm too famous
to be here."
Like, the narcissist
in my brain.
I'm like, "You guys,
we have to go."
And they're like,
"But there's fire."
And they're trying to
put the fire.
And I'm like,
"Guys, please no pictures."
And I'm hearing, "Fire."
And I'm like,
"I know I'm on fire.
Aah! We got to go.
We got to go."
So, finally,
I realize it's my hair.
I'm thinking they're telling me
I'm on fire.
Like, "Hey, baby, you know,
you're on fire."
And I'm like -- My hair had
completely caught on fire.
-Uh-huh.
-This man, who I thought was
attacking me in a club in Rome,
was actually saving my life.
So, when we leave,
me and my friends --
we're all talking about it.
"Can you believe that happened?"
Like, "I can't believe
I survived that.
Like, my hair.
We're shooting tomorrow."
So, we're with
a couple Italian guys.
They're like, "Yeah, everyone
was yelling 'fire' in the club."
And I was like, "Well, no, they
were yelling 'Cuoco.'
And he goes, "Well,
they were yelling 'fuoco,'
which means 'fire' in Italian."
And I was like, "Wait.
They weren't calling
my name in the club?"
-No one cares.
-No one knew who I was.
And I was convinced --
I'm telling you, one-letter
difference -- fuoco.
-And you're like,
"Whoa, they're attacking me.
No paparazzi, please.
Yes, of course.
We're hot. We're hot.
We're on fire. Yes."
-We laughed for days,
'cause they were like --
And they walked by -- A couple
of guys that I worked with
that were were like,
"Hey, Fuoco."
Like, it became a joke on set,
and they called me "Fuoco."
And I was like --
It was pretty insane, yeah.
-Well, I'm happy
you survived all of that
and thank that man
who saved you and saved --
-I was so mad at him.
But now, you know, at least
I can announce that he saved me.
I really thought
he was attacking me.
But, yeah,
he saved my life and my hair,
and I owe him a lot.
-Do you want to tell
everyone what
"The Flight Attendant" is about?
-Yes. It's about a boat captain.
I'm kidding.
It's about --
"The Flight Attendant" is about
a stewardess who lives her life
internationally, named Cassie.
She's, kind of like I said
earlier, a hot mess,
loves to drink,
has a lot of issues,
but she's a blast to be around.
And, you know, she goes home
with a passenger,
very good-looking passenger,
for her one night off
in Bangkok, in Thailand.
And she wakes --
They have a wild night.
They get completely blackout,
the time of their life,
and she wakes up
next to his dead body.
And her life is just hell for
the next eight episodes
and trying to figure out who did
this and exonerate herself
and also learn -- It gets
pretty dark as the episodes go
and kind of learning about
herself and her past.
-I want to show a clip.
Here is Kaley in
"The Flight Attendant"
on HBO Max.
Take a look at this.
-Where are you?
-Uh, I don't --
This place is so pretty.
-Yeah. No, okay.
That's not an answer.
Let's see.
Bangkok.
Oh, speaking of getting arrested
in foreign countries,
do not get arrested there.
The laws are, like, Byzantine.
-Right. Yeah.
How did you --
how did you know
that I'm in Bangkok?
-Oh, when we all took that
girls trip to Tulum,
we turned on our
"find friend" thing
'cause, like, kidnapping,
and, yeah, you just never turned
yours off, so...
Listen, you're not, like,
actually in trouble
or something, are you?
-No, I'm, uh...
hung over in Thailand.
-More with Kaley
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.
-Whoo!